hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to every
once in a while a film comes along that
challenges the way we will get cinema
life and reality itself a film that
dares to take risks be different and not
succumb to the rules and boundaries that
Hollywood has set up for them this my
friends is one of those movies I am of
course talking about the indescribable
genius of surf ninja now many of you may
look at this film and say hey this is
the white piece of shit I've ever paid
money to see but that's because you are
not seeing the true symbolic meaning
behind what looks like a gigantic load
of elephant dung or if we look at surf
ninjas with open eyes and critical
analysis we may see something deeper
than even the filmmakers could have
possibly imagined let's take a look
first of all I should point out that
this came out one year after three
ninjas which came out one year infinite
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles films which
is quite daring because many people can
mistake this for an even worse way off
of the Ninja Turtle franchise but no
this is an original construct of
unbelievable power
casting nothing short but the best of
Hollywood's acting talent including Fame
dramatic actor Leslie Nielsen whose film
work is still considered to be at the
height of cinematic excellence and who
can forget that legendary screen
presence Ernie Reyes jr. whose
incredible performances as magneto in
the run-down cemetery were number two in
India Jones and the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull still brings chills to the
movie going public and of course one of
the gems of American cinema who is said
to be the Marlon Brando of his
generation the master himself
Rob Schneider for indeed how can anyone
not swoon when he delivers such
brilliant lines as she's afraid to show
it she's
friendly not very objective and how
could you not cry when he recited all
his brilliant majesty don't make me come
out there and beat you at the league of
mine that no longer works and how can
you in all honesty not orgasm at the
delivery of such awesome power when he
says I've got two words to say to you
David Carradine and country our hearts
are with you perceptive angel so at the
beginning of this epic masterpiece we
find two brothers named Johnny and Adam
they are quote unquote surfer dudes who
hang out with their best friend Iggy
they take surfing so seriously that they
even treat their car as a surfboard
growing their way to school not caring
how nobody has their hand on the
steering wheel
putting dozens of lives at risk most
lovable rapscallions they're excited
because johnny is giving a speech in
high school about a visiting monk named
Baba Ram but unfortunately I would say
by the Bell he has totally forgotten
about the assignment I've got nothing
already the film has sucked you in with
its gut-wrenching suspense how will
Johnny get Ava's beat if he has nothing
prepared
perhaps a last-minute scribbling of
notes or a totally improvised speech or
of ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba course a
totally on-the-spot song rendition of
Barbara and a song that hasn't been
popular in decades and yet somehow
everyone in the school is dancing and
singing to its tubular melody genius but
little do they know that ninjas are
looking to kill the two boys as they
dress in the same color camouflage as
the Street Fighter movie this scene
right here is obviously referencing
Francis Ford Coppola Apocalypse Now
because as we all know they are both on
the exact same emotional wavelength
color his face and you must make a
friend of horror what's tall dark wears
a patch and always seems to be on my
butt it's almost as if for Coppola
directed both movies but luckily there's
a one-eyed Asian Charlie Chaplin to the
rescue his name is Zack and he tells the
two brothers that they are actually
princes of a far-off land called
- son Fortis and uh you mean those
toilets construction sites yeah this may
seem like a lame joke but it's not it's
genius so that tells the brothers about
the island of POTUS on was the most
peaceful place on earth and one day the
people gathered to celebrate the birth
of Crown Prince Otto and his brother
Crown Prince yoni before mercenary
devastated our country notice the low
angle shot here that's to indicate that
Leslie Nielsen is the bad guy I'm often
reminded of the low angle shots in
Citizen Kane the greatest movie of all
time
don't worry about me I'm sure I can we
just want to drive but the man will let
us can you see the emotional
similarities to these magnum opus
I challenge you to say no also notice
Leslie Nielsen's look of absolute evil
when he approaches young dodge that
still haunts my nightmares so Nielson
gets knocked over and gets half of his
face watched by an elephant
amid seem like he's standing in that
spot on purpose or even getting under
the elephant for no apparent reason but
my thought is that's much like bow Todd
and the shattering of his spear he knows
his destiny and instead of running away
from it he embraces his doom the
collaboration of zoom shots and what
seems like lazy editing Oh genius so
thus Nielson has to wear a plastic mask
on half of his face no doubt symbolizing
the duality of his character in any
other film this will look positively
retarded but because it's in this film
it works meanwhile we see that little
Adam has the whimsical power to see
images of the future and what device
does he use to harness his visions not
fumes from the cracks
the earthling me Oracle not an enchanted
fountain like the mayor of Galadriel but
rather a second Game Gear that shows
Adam exactly what's going to happen in a
matter of seconds it's like the legends
of Greek mythology will them again
also notice the use of Playboy magazines
here even though this is so obviously a
children's film always pushing the
envelope this movie challenging us with
the threat of sexual arousal so that
takes Johnny Adams and of course a
horrible icky to the center headquarters
of all the padosan people a Chinese
restaurant the best part is sunny food
in LA there Johnny's introduced to his
future wife who is arranged to marry him
prove that people don't need to have
relationships or similar interests as
long as they are both attractive true
love will shine free but the ninjas
arrived and so Johnny must discover his
true ability as a ninja warrior not
through years of physical training not
through the hardships of mental wisdom
but to imagine notice the use of
Beethoven's Ode to Joy no doubt exactly
the subject matter he had in mind when I
wrote this every piece note also that
the ninjas rather than get up and fight
some more or how did the way is it to
say I have my chance and now I must let
others take my place these guys are
going where no other film dares after a
local cop gets thrown into the mix our
heroes set ashore to the island of
padosan here we hear more of the
characters wonderful dialogue as they
quote such timeless phrases that will
know about never age
but it's Thailand fully bonuses next red
laser combat psych no worries bro in
Division one
how could they have predicted that
phrases like psych and pumping would
still be words used even to this day
I'll tell you how genius so while on the
island they come across even more nasty
ninjas who hold our heroes hostage but
wait a minute
Coyle Adam has an idea ah yes running
over the ninjas with their cheap
notice how the ninjas and no point ever
used their guns to stop the oncoming
threat even though they have plenty of
time to do so how fascinating so they
take the Jeep while fighting off the
other soldiers with the ninjas most
ancient weapon of battle dynamite ha ha
that will show those who value human
life as a treasured gift as if this film
hasn't taken enough risks already they
actually dared to make a brave
anti-smoking statement in the middle of
a chase scene of us cigarettes yeah yeah
I know I should quit maybe you should
get the pack
look on top yes inspired poet let us all
look into the deepest areas of our soul
and see who we are talking to G to the e
to the N with an i us a genius which is
quite interesting seeing how this girl
says Playboy's are good and yet smoking
is bad mixed messages or conflicting
issues not not who they are genius after
the chasing zoj gives them all sacred
headbands made out of tie-dye shirts and
since what's left of their bodacious RV
to the village evil fortress not since
the ending of Stanley Kubrick's past the
glorious collection of warriors and
fighters seems so powerful and so moving
I dare you not to shed a tear while
watching this awesome display the only
problem is the villains fortress is
surrounded by another large stretch of
water how can our heroes possibly cross
o course turn the trees and desert Fords
absolutely brilliant even though these
people have never served a day in their
lives
Johnny's their fearless teacher
instructs them well remember bend your
knees you you and that's all you need
bend your knees and swing your arms
surfing in two seconds socket Scorsese
but as if that wasn't enough this film
is also brave enough to confront racial
sensibilities as well brother don't
start just get back to this
yes brothers don't surf bringing it to
the light a stereotype I didn't even
know existed
and I will one emergency what seems to
be the problem yes I should be having
overwhelming about it sure so our heroes
infiltrate the heavily guarded fortress
armed not with swords not with guns but
with giant yellow flag that should throw
off the military armed goons
they are so terrified at the poetry of
the moment that they don't even have
time to use their guns and instead just
fling themselves at the invading troops
now I know what a lot of you are
thinking how could they possibly have
those flags when they so obviously
didn't bring them over on their
surfboards well I'll tell you how so
finally we get to the big showdown with
Leslie Nielsen of lawyer Johnny Nielsen
and Johnny's start to fight but
Nielsen's mechanical hand starts to
malfunction and forces him to start um
jerking off now I know a lot of you are
wondering why nerd do they put that
scene there well I'll tell you why I
have absolutely no clue I think it's
pretty fucking disgusting so Johnny
defeats the evil villain brings order to
pot Assad and makes a breathtaking
speech that even Barack Obama will cry
cuz I was born into royalty I'm no
different from you put my face on a
stamp 50 cent piece and let's call it a
day and what epic masterpiece wouldn't
be complete without another rendition of
ba Baba Ram as Baba Ram himself sings
the song while wearing a beautiful
necklace of yak testicles so let's surf
ninjas one of the greatest movies nono
greatest things of all time
how can a movie be so great so wonderful
and so unbelievably groundbreaking
because there's no moving like surf
ninjas
there's no moving like surf ninjas
there's no movie like surf ninjas
there's no movie when ninjas smell just
ridic no feel like surf ninjas nostalgia
critic in chess there's no film like
stock up Oh
Fargo huh
Mike what happened to me you got shot in
the head pretty good there nostalgia
critic but oh how did it happen well
that was me I shot you in the head sorry
I'm a Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't sorry I bad mom I had the most
horrible dream and you were there and
you and you really no I
I dreamt I was watching a horrible
horrible movie and I liked it
what was it surfing chess and how was it
moved out a little piece of retro shit
my yeah ok ok calm down calm down
oh but I'm me again this is my room and
you're all hearing glorious brown and
white and I'm never ever gonna like
anything ever ever again
Remo well
I heard one said along
but wait a minute if I got shot in the
head that how did I survive Optimus
Prime
remember I died for your sins
you know I really show up on the top
eleven sass nostalgic moments yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was stupid
you